the race to vaccinate is even more
urgent due to the new more contagious
variants of the virus debra patta got
rare access to a lab in south africa
studying one such mutation that appears
to be resistant to antibodies an
important form of treatment
debra has more on this from johannesburg
virus hunters in this high-risk
biohazard lab in durban
are hot on the trail of the mutant
strain spreading at
breakneck speed across south africa the
virus has mutated to attach
more easily to human cells the disease
is no more deadly but it spreads more
easily
we do believe that we are going through
a new pandemic yeah
which these variants that not only
transmit much faster
but that also potentially has less
neutralization
genetic scientist julio de oliveira
discovered the new variant
after observing a dramatic uptick in
infections in november
south african hospitals are overwhelmed
mortuaries overcrowded
and burial plots in short supply de
oliveira's colleagues in the highly
secured lab
have developed a live culture of the
strain to speed up
research the new strain here seems to
have the ability to reduce the
effectiveness of antibodies
in people infected in the first wave by
how much
so tenfold would be conservative
you can also have complete knockouts
where there'd be no
response at all that's right this means
that those infected in the first wave
could have little protection from the
new strain even more troubling
it could render some of the vaccines
less effective
it's clear that we've underestimated
this virus on the other hand the
evidence is not there yet
that vaccines will be affected and
certainly
people should keep vaccinating because
that's the solution
to this pandemic here at the country's
central lab scientists stressed
immunity is only part of the problem
results on just how effective the
vaccines are against the new strain
aren't you for a couple of weeks but in
the future vaccines may have to be
tweaked every now and again
to protect against mutant strains just
like the annual flu shot gail
all right deborah powder reporting from
johannesburg thank you